- [Voiceover] We're told the graph of y
equals two to the x is shown below,
so that's the graph.
It's an exponential function.
Which of the following is a graph of y
is equal to negative one times two
to the x plus three plus four?
They give us four choices down here.
Before we even look
closely at those choices,
let's just think about what this
would look like if it was
transformed into that.
You might notice that what we have here,
this y that we wanna find the graph of,
is a transformation of this original one.
How do we transform it?
We've replaced x with x plus three.
Then we multiplied that by negative one,
and then we add four.
Let's take it step by step.
This is y equals two to the x.
What I wanna do next is let's graph y
is equal to two to the x
plus three power.
If you replace x with x plus three,
you're going to shift the graph
to the left by three.
That might be a little
bit counterintuitive,
but when we actually
think about some points,
it'll hopefully make some sense here.
For example, over in our original graph,
when x is equal to zero,
y is equal to one.
How do we get y equal
one for our new graph,
for this thing right over here?
To get y equals one
here, the exponent here
still has to be zero, so
that's going to happen
at x equals negative three.
That's going to happen at
x equals negative three.
Y is equal to one.
Notice, we shifted to the left
by three.
Likewise, in our original graph,
when x is two, y is four.
How do we get y equals four in this thing
right over here?
For y to be equal to
four, this exponent here
needs to be equal to two,
and so for this exponent
to be equal to two, 'cause
two squared is four,
for this exponent to be equal to two,
x is going to be equal to negative one.
When x is equal to negative one,
y is equal to four.
Notice we shifted to the left
by three.
So this thing, which isn't our final graph
that we're looking for, is gonna look
something like,
like that, which shifted,
it's y equals two to the x,
shifted to the left by three.
Now let's figure out what the graph of,
now let's multiply this
expression times negative one.
Notice we're slowly building up
to our goal.
Now let's figure out the graph of y
is equal to negative one times two
to the x plus three.
Here, when y equals two
to the x plus three,
if we multiply that times negative one,
whatever y we had, we're gonna have
the negative of that.
Instead of when x is
equal to negative three
having positive one, when
x equals negative three,
you're gonna have negative one.
We multiplied by negative one.
When x is equal to negative
one, instead of having four,
you're going to have negative four.
Our graph is gonna be flipped over,
it's flipped over the x axis.
It's going to look something
like this.
This is not a perfect
drawing, but it'll give us
a sense of things, and we can look
at which of these graphs match up to that.
Then finally, we wanna
add that four there.
We wanna figure out the graph of y
equals negative one times two to the x
plus three plus four.
We wanna take what we just had
and shift it up by four.
Instead of this being a
negative one right over here,
this is going to be a negative one
plus four is three.
Instead of this being a negative four,
negative four plus four is zero.
Instead of our horizontal asymptote
being at y equals zero,
our horizontal asymptote
is going be at y equals four.
It's gonna look like, let me draw,
I can do a better job than that.
Our horizontal asymptote is gonna
be right over there, so our graph is going
to look something like
this.
We just shifted that red graph up by four.
Shifted it up by four.
We have a horizontal
asymptote at y equals four.
Let's look at which of
these choices match that.
Choice A right over here
has a horizontal asymptote
at y equals four, but it is shifted
on the horizontal
direction inappropriately.
In fact, it looks like it might have not
been shifted to the left.
We can rule this one out.
Let's rule that one out.
This one over here,
this one approaches our
asymptote as x increases,
so that's not right.
It should approach our asymptote
as x decreases, so we ruled that one out.
Choice C looks like what we just graphed.
Horizontal asymptote at x equals four.
When x equals negative
three, y is equal to three.
That's what we got.
When x is equal to negative one,
y is equal to zero.
This looks right.
You could even try those points out.
We like choice C.
D is clearly off.
There's another way that
you could have tackled this.
I like tackling it with
a transformation way
'cause you could see how you got from two
to the x to this right over here.
But you could have just
thought it through and ya said,
when x becomes really, really, really,
really negative, this
term is going to become
really, really, really small, and if this
is approaching zero, then
even if you multiply it
by negative one, it's going
to be a negative number
approaching zero, but we're
going to approach four,
this whole expression is
going to approach four
from below.
You're going to have
that horizontal asymptote
at y equals four.
Then you could try out two values.
You could just say,
you could just do something like this,
x and y.
You could say when x is,
as x approaches negative infinity,
y is going to approach positive four.
When x is going to be
negative three, when x is negative three,
y is going to be positive three.
You can calculate that.
Two to the negative three plus three.
That's two to the zero, which
is one times negative one,
which is negative one plus four is three.
Then you could say when x is equal
to negative one, negative
one plus three is two.
Two squared is four.
Four times negative one is negative four
plus four is zero.
Another way you could have done it
is if you'd thought about
the horizontal asymptote
and you found two interesting points,
you could have said, "Which
of these matches that?"
The only one that does is
this one right over here,
negative three, comma, three.
Negative one, comma, zero.
Horizontal asymptote at y equals four.
You'd be all done.
Either way, hopefully, you enjoyed that.